faut jamais transigé avec la vérité
et avec le bien des enfants
[Musique]
cet été françoise cavale et découvre des
photomontages quelque peu licencieuse
sur des corps aux poses lascives ont été
collées des visages d'élèves
l'histoire remonterait à une dizaine
d'années serait l'oeuvre d'un professeur
discrètement muté inutile d'en faire
étalage conseils quant à françoise
caballé on a essayé d'obtenir le silence
par des propos maternelle de la part de
la directrice diocésaine ma voiture a
été vandalisée l'appartement de fonction
que j'occupe est a été mis à sac ma
fille a fait l'objet de menaces
d'enlèvement s'étaler jusqu'à
une offre financière justement parce que
j'ai choisi l'enseignement catholique
j'estime que mon devoir est de dénoncer
il doit être dénoncé quand ça se
présente
je ne me suis pas posé la question j'ai
simplement agi avec le coeur et quand on
a en charge une école on n'a pas d'autre
choix
ça s'impose ça n'est même pas une
question de choix c'est une question
d'engagement émoi chez les parents
d'élèves on veut changer leur directrice
françoise caballé du collège privé ça
[ __ ] dejouany voit le diocèse lui retirer
son agrément
officiellement le renvoi de françoise
cavaler a pour motif la gestion
désastreuse de l'établissement et la
dégradation de ses relations avec les
professeurs et sa tutelle
m
des faits similaires dénoncé aujourd'hui
ne s'inscrirait pas dans le même
contexte il y à 25 ans
j'étais dans une situation de pot de
terre rencontrant un pot de fer ma
parole peser bien peu dans un contexte
d' omerta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]